hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game where an excellent
subscriber challenges the almighty stock
fish i promised you another game before
we uh go into uh well at least 10 more
days of excruciating top level chess as
the melt welder champion chess tour is
about to resume uh today uh so uh here
gabriel campos uh sent me a game uh he
played against stockfish and i get a lot
of games people playing in stockfish
mostly it's a games people where people
have defeated stockfish uh and uh some
of them are like incredible games of 200
moves where they either defeated or got
a drug in stockfish but uh here uh
gabriel actually sent me a game where he
lost the stockfish but it was such a fun
game that he decided to
share it with me and i i liked it so
much that i wanted to
share it with everyone so i asked the
gabriel if he would um you know send me
a photo of his to use in the video so
here it is so thank you for that and now
let's enjoy this game
and uh see why uh why it's uh so
enjoyable uh so uh stockfish with the
white pieces opens with e4 and uh that's
not true stocks actually opened with
this game with the d4 and i just wanted
to mention uh gabriel also said that
this game was played in 2020 so it was
not the 2022 stock fish but still 2020
stockfish is uh
i mean uh just an absolute absolute
monster that's okay we have d4 gabriel
replies with d5 we have c4 going for the
queen's gambit and e6 declining the
gambit we have knight to f3 and gabriel
goes for c5 he plays the pseudotaras
defense
c captures on d5 and now not e captures
on the e5 which is the standard idea uh
he plays queen captures on d5 and this
is already uh very very dangerous you
are allowing stockfish knights to c3
this comes with tempo as the black queen
will be attacked you will have to move
the queen and giving a player of
stockfish
strength uh an extra move can be can be
deadly so knights to c3 stockfish
doesn't pass on this opportunity to grab
a full tempo queen back to d8 and now
comes pawn to e4
uh and now uh you really have to just
admit white is ahead in development
white is better you you can capture for
example play a6 take away the b5 square
from white's pieces and hope that you
can start developing pieces and finish
development uh before white absolutely
uh crosses or crushes you as you can see
and none of the black pieces have been
developed but here instead of
let's say something like this knight the
c6 was played and uh it is as of move
six that we have a completely new game
so this has never been seen before and
for a very good reason this allows
stockfish to strike immediately in the
center with the d5 and stockfish does
this the knight is attacked and now
knight back to b8 now you could also
capture but we're going to capture with
the pawn and the knight will still have
to move so again black has this issue
of it being move seven already and none
of the pieces have been developed with
bishop to b5 with check bishop to d7
blocking and now stockfish brings the
bishop back to c4 putting more pressure
on e6 and uh well if the position opens
up we could even go after the f7 pawn so
here knight to g5 this is exactly what
stockfish does uh or rather sorry first
a6 we have knight to g5 goes after the
f7 and e6 squares
and here gabriel gives stockfish a
deadly there here gabriel plays h6 and
of course you guys don't even need to
pause the video to uh figure out what
stalkers played of course stockfish
sacrificed the knight with knight
captures on f7 and now what what can
gabriel do here uh his rook is hanging
and also the queen is hanging so the
knight kind of has to be captured or you
could play some like queen to f6 for
activity but even this doesn't really
give black all that much you only have a
queen developed so it's not much of an
activity so here king characters on f7
was played and now comes d captures an
e6 with check this is the idea behind
the sacrifice the bishop cannot capture
as the queen on the e8 is undefended the
queen will hang so after d captures an
e6 with check we have king to e8 uh and
now comes queen to h5 with check again
as stockfish with the perfect move
every every move that's uh unfortunately
for us humans how how stockfish plays we
have g6 and queen captures on g6 we have
king to e7 and now for the crushing it
uh
well uh of course the mate in five
knights to d5 with check king to d6 and
now bishop to f4 with check the black
king has no squares uh aside from the c6
square yeah but that will be the last
square that the black king visits with
king to c6 and now pawn to e7 would
check opening up a discovery um
from the queen and you can see bishop
covers the b5 square knight covers the
b6 square also knight and bishop covered
the c7 square so the black king again
and nowhere to go we have to block with
something knight to f6 was played and
here stockfish can play anything but
it's actually a forced mate in one and
of course you will see it e captures on
d8 promoting uh another knight into the
game so stockfish gets the third knight
which delivers checkmate by entering the
game and that's it you can see this what
uh what uh what uh what a massacre this
game was so uh thank you very much
gabriel for for sending this to us and
if you think okay this uh wasn't uh
played all that impressively by black uh
you you would be surprised that it
doesn't matter how good of a player you
are uh once you play stockfish uh every
everyone uh everyone's game pretty much
looks like this it could be 20 2000 2100
2200 2300 2400 uh stockfish will just
obliterate you and there is no uh
there's simply no way out of this you
can try this uh you know try try playing
stockfish and you know yeah if you if
you need to
maybe maybe feel a bit humble uh or you
know grateful to be alive uh then
challenge stockfish uh to a game uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and thank you gabriel very
very much for for uh sending us this
this masterpiece by our uh artificial
friend uh i would like to thank david
kimura john guilfoyle dominic novieli
adam rosenberg and francis air for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon as today is the start of
the meltwater champions chess tour so we
are gonna have a lot of great games to
cover uh so yeah i thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and you know uh be like
gabriel uh if you even if you lose the
game you can still enjoy it and share it
with everyone because that's the that's
the beauty of chess uh see you soon